>>Mark: You know, when
I first started here,
I felt like we were doing the
same thing over and over again,
and we were wondering why
our kids weren't buying in.
We were running traditional
public schools,
but we weren't really
embracing innovation and change.
>>If we're not getting the success,
then it's an innovation we should
do away with and try another.
>>I really saw my role as, how do we,
on a limited budget,
really reinvent ourselves?
>>Patrick: All right,
good, that's perfect.
>>Student: Yes!
>>Mark: To move your vision
along, people need to buy in,
they need to trust you as a leader.
So for us, it's always been about
collaboration, working together.
This commitment to putting students
at the forefront of our decisions.
>>How do you like the new building?
>>Student: I love it a lot.
>>Mark: Good, good.
>>For our district, four
key areas of work
in Meriden are creating student
centered learning environment,
technology integration,
expanding learning time
and building district capacity.
>>Student: We'll test conductivity,
density and then make
a data table after.
>>Brenda: Okay.
>>Mark: First, we want to create
schools where students want to be.
What they were telling us is, when you
allow us to work with other students
and solve real world
problems, we learn better,
we enjoy it more and we feel challenged.
So how do we support our
teachers in this transition?
We have student centered
learning coaches.
>>Patrick: As a coach, I
would work with teachers.
We try to find ways to build in
student centered learning activities
in every single classroom, where
kids have more opportunities
to learn from each other.
>>Jake: Student centered learning
provides us with a better outlook
of what real life is going to be.
It feels like you're experiencing
something, rather than taking notes
on something and having a test
on it the next week, it's fun.
>>He runs away because he's guilty.
>>Mia: End scene.
[applause]
>>Mark: We also knew
that if we were going
to create student centered
learning environment,
we needed to make sure technology
was in place for students,
so they can learn anywhere
and at any time.
>>What made you guys choose
the white tigers to study?
>>Student: We saw that the
white tiger was very majestic.
>>Daniel: When we went
to one to one devices,
the district did an outstanding job
of supporting classroom
teachers, offering PLC time.
We had technology integration
specialists.
We also have something
called tech buddies.
>>Patrick: There's no reason
that we can't take those experts
in our buildings, our older students,
and have them work with
our younger students.
>>Sergio: And E is right next to it.
>>Lauren: Using the technology
is really motivating
for these twenty-first century
learners; that's how they learn.
>>Nayeilli: See how easy that was?
>>Mark: Next, it was that we were going
to expand learning opportunities
for students.
We heard about some of the creative
work that was occurring in other schools
and we said, why can't that occur here?
So we applied for an
AFT innovation grant,
where students go a hundred minutes more
per day, forty additional days a year.
Not every elementary teacher needs
to work eight thirty to three thirty.
Some could work seven thirty to two
thirty, others will work nine to four.
The results there have been
tremendous, academic results,
standardized testing results,
climate survey results.
>>Teacher: Okay, tell me why though.
>>Student: It felt crunchy.
>>Teacher: Excellent.
>>Mark: So by flexing teachers'
schedules, having the union's agreement
to do that, we're doing
creative things that kids love.
>>Very good, give me five.
Okay, good work.
>>Another innovation is how
we build district capacity,
how we support our staff
and create the initiatives,
especially during these
tough budget times.
Here at Hanover, we have a
program for students with autism
and other communication disorders.
>>Jennifer: What we were doing
for special education
students before we had a lot
of outside agencies working with them.
>>Mark: I thought to myself, why are
shipping them to a school so far away?
And the answer was, we don't have
the staff, we don't have the space,
we don't have the programs.
I'm thinking, well, staff,
we hire teachers.
Space, we can always be creative, and
programs, I love designing programs.
We can do better.
>>Heather: Are you ready to go?
Listen, go.
>>Mark: We are the only district
in Connecticut whose special
ed population has increased,
but the overall expenses have went down,
because we've done service internally.
>>Jennifer: Mark is forward thinking
and that's what I love
about being a principal.
Under his leadership, I
am able to try things.
>>Mark: Leadership is about making
people comfortable to take risks.
If you're not willing to fail,
you're never going to be innovative
and you're never going to be
as successful as you should be.
>>Ah, I'm tired!
>>Student: Don't give up!
>>Mark: Never give up, never give up!